if I you want to read a serious Deadpool
story that's not a comedy Deadpool story
read the good the bad the ugly from the
newest post saying Doug and Ron it's him
teaming up with Captain America
Wolverine involves his daughter it
involves a bunch of cloned Korean x-men
so you'll love that okay I can teach you
everything you want know about Deadpool
right now right now you're something
guys hear something guys he was made by
Rob Liefeld he was a 1990s action
character when he first showed up in New
musician number 98 and then Joe Kelly
got him at 97 turn him into a parody and
then Chris referee Scott and like 1999
or something like that and that's what
he's had a break in the fourth wall all
the time yep and that's what pisses me
off when people when you say to people
what was funny about Deadpool they go oh
he breaks the football that on its own
is enough funny like there's anything
that's a thing that happens that's not a
character I think I knew a dude whose
favorite character was um was was a
Silver Surfer because he was the most
powerful Mike that's not a reason to
like anything when i upload this part
when i was weakly pulled won't have your
camera but if you don't care i don't
care that's bizarre Michelle doesn't
care he's like fun i'm not gonna be on
camera that I'm taking off these pants
that i don't have to do this show come
on i'm gonna be on camera when it
broadcasts on twitter I'll be like I'll
be there that's the hardest part about
doing these lashes I gonna like comb my
hair and put pants on and stuff dude I
love any caps hot fries yeah they're so
good I know if we have those in Canada
we're have blockers crisps though yeah
which are just bad lays but you see
that's the thing is someone who has lays
I think Walker's has the superior
flavors beef and onion cheese and all
these other flavors that we don't get
North yeah I mean we got fetch of
flavors but we get less in the bag and
they're actually made in the US and then
flown over here because it's the same
logo is lays its just Walker's not lays
yeah cuz when they first came to UK lays
was actually a brand of kitchen paper Oh
apparently they do that in other
countries in the world to like Saudi
Arabia it's called chip see even though
it's still lays in
a walker and still everything else hmm I
have images corresponding with our
discussion so nice when they go up
though uh a pop-up good god I got the
list up in front of me sped them what I
would have done I would I just that like
kesha in one cigar right lady gaga and
the other yeah and glitter and the other
one there's something wonderfully trashy
about her it's like shorty love only
without the danger I love it just
because I love the concept of let's say
everyone thinks like one person's dumb
when they come across as like
extraordinarily dumb then you actually
get in Burma children it's like holy
[ __ ] you know were you talking about but
what if you still seem dumb right wow
what is happening oh one thing that I
wanted to ask um that um yeah we talked
about Gwen pull yeah we can miss we can
talk about it sure here hang on let me
get a picture ever I haven't seen that
yet as Gwen pool been in something yet
are they still hype in our specials
she's Marvel's holiday special this year
uh I don't think she's been anything I
just want to talk about cuz she looked
she get him amazing was she gonna be in
the back up of like a Howard the Duck or
is that after the special she becomes a
backup in Howard the Duck I don't know I
haven't no I thought she was getting
roaring komak no I think yes I think
she's getting a one-shot like I think
that so it's a one-shot then back up
stories then they're gonna take it from
there they're basically doing the spider
gwine model is what they say yeah it's
gonna be really [ __ ] popular among
like 50 puzzle Yetta gonna run with it
yeah spider Gwen was the third
best-selling comic of the month of
October like right next to amazing
spider-man and Iron Man it was number
three I couldn't believe that it was Oh
model for the top 10 in October I know I
could I could definitely believe that
well like people ask me where ask me
during the Commerce of coffee like what
DC books am I reading I'm like uh Batman
good question right yeah but uh what
happened like what are your favorite DC
books like a green arrows can haz right
how much under yeah under Benjamin Percy
they finally stopped trying to make it
like the TV show wrote which is nice if
he has his politics back he's finally
these fighting like a skeleton cartels
in Juarez right now it's great
I at the moment meeting Titans hun cuz
it's not terrible right that's active
episode about we talked about you fast I
don't know if you caught the Epis
although you know I don't think anything
will top via mention I got in a your
Jubilee back at use when it's just when
Tim was saying it's okay i guess
canadians get you know confused for each
other all the time Joel probably gets
confused for Wolverine every day that's
true well keep your dad I wanted but
just don't look like you're keeping your
distance and i want to write back that's
like hey I'm just as Harry and just as
angry and on just as many teams but I'm
at least taller you that that is true
that is unarguably what I got it if you
got ya know oh great big bottle of
straight bourbon whiskey from Buffalo
Trace it is this the drunk cast this is
what is gonna make every time I'm not
gonna take shots in the middle though
sure if Benny was here he'd be
challenging you to go oh come on you
react we are lives with their awesome